okay okay
um
so now we have none less than man beer
pigs all the way
from australia i love the profile
picture though that doesn't do
dude indeed look like a man or pig
maybe those exist in australia who knows
wouldn't rule it out
what's the time in australia now it must
be pretty late
probably like one in the morning
yeah i think it must be something like
that
but regardless of whether you're a man
bear
or a pig or all of the above
you gotta show up that's the first order
of the day
you gotta show off for the game
maybe man beer pig just wanted
wanted the attention without having to
play the game
okay nine
eight seven six
what comes after six five
four three two
one sorry member pig you're out
wow well
we need uh we need vir here
what's man bear peak in time okay i'm
not going to waste any more time i'm
just going to play the game
you got lucky sir
and we're getting a rat let's just spend
all this time preparing for the rat
that is so nasty if that's the case
keep me waiting and then just preparing
for the rat
no i don't think so i don't think he's
prepared because this is not a great
line
i mean white is doing okay but there are
worse lines for sure
basically here now i have two threats
one which is called rook g2
and the other one which is to go knight
c6 and attack d4
as well and there
yeah the queen e4 is a reasonable way to
deal with both
this is not this is not like scary stuff
for
a black girl there we go knight c6
anyway
marking it alphabets
d5 i think i'm going f5
just uh absolute cavemen style
hiding my assets in the caveman island
rook g4 now
generally it's a good strategy and bless
this one
just attack stuff on every move and
especially when your opponent has
brought
his queen out at an early stage that is
a very
valuable piece which means that you can
win very valuable time
by attacking said very valuable peace
and now after
after i would have had a double attack
which means that green
f2 is a lot better
um yeah
it's actually not so obvious through
here
quindy 5 is tempting
but is that any good fish d4
richie screen
queen e3 but then i can very least take
on c2 with some murky compensation
if bishop d4 oh there's not c3
immediately
as well yeah i guess that stuff doesn't
work
so what should i do then
i guess i'll just go [ __ ] g7
developing stuff i ic3 seems to be
clearly the best move
um what to do now
it's definitely posing some questions
now
c5 castles
queen a5 man does look a bit
loose but i guess i'll go for it
i didn't see a lot of promising
alternatives to be fair
because if he if he does have time to go
knight e2
with impunity then then i think he's
just doing fine
so now after 92 i'm going to take it and
regardless of
how he captures a2 is going to be
hanging in his is his king is going to
be
um going to be fairly exposed
maybe not f3 is an option though knight
takes f3 gfc
i've got roof g6 still threatening
mission tank c3 i'm probably not doing
great here
it's really really murky
so i'm not i'm not majorly worried
but i don't think i'm really fantastic
yeah it's playing it's playing well
this particular creature
[Music]
rook t3 i think can be met by b6
possibly
with the idea of bishop a6 next
[Music]
which seems very hard to meet
also b6 of course protects c5 which is
not an insignificant detail
bishop c5 now is probably critical
then i'll take on c3 and then probably
an a2
don't refresh to take on a2 or c3
and um yeah um
in lack of anything better i'll take it
from there
i think i've taken c3 actually seems
that um the queen is covering a few more
squares from them
bish b6 developing
and protecting against making two
what more can you ask of a single move
bishop d4 seems quite plausible then
queen a3
check measure b2 queen takes a2
and for the moment i seem to be doing
fine there
uh my position is shaky for sure
but i don't think he has anything too
direct
it's going to be interesting to see note
also that the queen
protects e6 from a2
i have to say my opponent is playing an
excellent game
certainly the outcome from here is
uh yeah it's not even close to being
clear
so rook c8 and now i'm i'm just hoping
that after queen h8 rook g8
i'm gonna have rook c2 later on
oh he just goes back surprising
now rook c2 i guess doesn't work because
b2
is protected so rook g2 later on doesn't
have a lot of sting
i guess i'll try to exchange queensland
i gotta move sir
okay yeah bishop d5
trying to to retain that extra pawn
i'll try just try and be cheeky and
retain this one bishop
six was probably good move i would have
gotten
king f7 there now i think i'm in control
um consolidated anything upon up and
obviously he's losing sometimes
okay sir very good game and hopefully
that was
well uh worth uh
staying up for